tulsi gabbard is a former presidential
candidate and former congresswoman of
hawaii
tulsi it is striking when you see
putin propaganda and you line it up
against biden propaganda
do you think that we're at risk of
kind of moving in that direction right
now
we are moving in that direction jesse
and and your question there what are
they so afraid of they're afraid of the
truth they're afraid of even a single
voice coming out as challenging the
power elite questioning them daring to
hold a dissenting view and they're
afraid because their arguments are so
weak that that they know they will not
withstand the light of the truth and
this is why we're seeing not only still
most of the mainstream media very
vigorously uh defending and pushing
the biden propaganda
it's not enough they're going to
youtubers they're going to tick talkers
it's not enough that they also have
google and big tech basically working
for them and with them to control what
information we see and what information
we don't see none of this is enough
because they won't stop and it's not
just the bite administration it's not
just democrats it's the power lead it's
the neocons and the neolibs working
together to make sure that every single
voice in this country anybody who's got
a platform is spouting their narrative
that they want people to see and hear
their propaganda and this is what's so
dangerous about the place that we're in
right now uh as a country
where this idea this principle this
foundation of freedom of speech freedom
of expression uh is directly under
threat and under attack and you're right
it's not so different what's happening
here is not so different from what we're
seeing happening in russia where you've
got state tv and controlled messaging
across the board this is this is where
we're at it worked so well for them
during covid if you questioned anything
they wanted to knock you off social
media they wanted to get you in trouble
because you were seen as a danger to
other people and now they're trying the
same playbook with the war in ukraine if
you ask any questions if you say hey
maybe the no-fly zone's not such a great
idea or
express any sort of reservation about
launching into a land war in asia
that's now
something we're not even allowed to
debate do you think that really shows
how weak
their arguments are because if you're if
you're confident in your argument you
know hey let's hash it out we're
americans let's debate this we get the
best idea and we put it forward isn't
that how it's supposed to be
that's exactly what our founders had in
mind uh for this country is the strength
of this public discourse the town square
people being able to argue and debate
uh and and actually air their ideas and
their views and
maybe finding hey their strengths here
there's weaknesses here let's come out
with the best possible solution that
best serves the interest of the american
people
and our country they are afraid they
refuse to argue based on substance of
one position versus another because of
that weakness of their position so
instead of saying okay let's have a
dialogue let's have a debate and a
discussion uh they instead immediately
resort to name-calling smears character
assassination silencing and censorship
that is not who we are as america and
that it will undermine our democratic
republic if it's allowed to continue i
agree the american people are not
obstacles
all right that's what they think we are
we're not obstacles tulsa gabbard thank
you
thanks jesse